-Justin Thomas,
It is great to see you.
Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-I have to mention something
because I was
looking at you before the show.
And you have a giant scrape
on your face there.
-Yeah.
-Can we zoom in?
Can we see that in camera
three maybe or four?
Yeah.
-Yeah, I got a little --
-So I thought maybe you just got
in a fight or something,
you know, as golfers do.
[ Laughter ]
You went out there and just
scrapped with somebody.
And you did.
-Yeah. Yeah.
No, it was an intense battle
on the golf course, and --
-Yeah.
-It actually wasn't that.
-What was the name of this guy
that attacked you?
-This is Dale.
[ Audience aws ]
-Yeah, Dale.
-This was before he attacked me,
for the record.
-So he gave you a kiss first
and then he attacked you.
-Yes.
-That brutal beast, Dale.
-I mean, look at him.
He's a monster.
-Looks like a tough guy.
Yeah, absolutely.
Who is Dale to you?
-So, it's my fiancé's
maid of honor.
We were in Chicago this past
weekend and we stayed at
their house, and woke up in
the morning and Dale was there
and greeted us while we were
in bed, and...
-There you go.
-This is what happened.
-I want to congratulate you,
by the way.
Last week you played in the
Presidents Cup on Team USA,
and you guys won.
Come on!
That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-It's got to be exciting.
That's a big moment right there.
-Oh, yeah.
-I know Jordan Spieth,
your buddy, you won with him.
You're best friends?
-That's what the media says.
Yeah, I guess we're gonna buy
into that.
-Yeah, I'll buy into it.
But you guys played together.
Are you competitive still?
Or you go, now we're teammates?
-Well, I guess in that
situation, no, we're teammates.
It's nice because I've been
playing with him for so long
and watching his game,
I know what he's capable of.
And it's really nice to be
rooting for him as opposed to
not rooting against him,
but maybe not rooting
for him like I do normally.
-As best friends would do.
Yeah, as friends would do, yeah.
-So, I guess,
yes, we are competitive.
-Yeah, I think so, too.
You did something I thought was
pretty cool on Instagram.
You posted your goals
for the year.
And take a look at these.
Why do you post this
out to the public?
To put more pressure on you?
-I don't know.
It's something I've done.
I've always felt like I've liked
making goals and just --
you know, I have some that are
more achievable than others
and I have some
that are more difficult.
But I make everybody on my team
do it.
So my caddie will do it. My dad,
who's my coach, will do it.
My putting coach will do it.
You know, I'll do some stuff
with my trainer.
Because then --
And then I make everybody
share it with each other,
so everybody's held accountable.
And I think it's -- when I go
back to it at the end of the
year, I'm able to, you know, see
what I did, what I didn't do.
And then if somebody on my team
says that they were going to do
something in their goals and
they don't do it,
well, they're the one
that wrote their own goal,
so I'm able to get on them
a little bit.
-Hey, come on.
-Yeah.
-How is it having your dad be
that close to you
with your career?
-It's great. It's great.
We have an unbelievable
relationship.
I think we've done a really good
job over the past, you know,
handful of years of -- well,
one was probably me maturing.
Maybe my stubbornness got
out of the way a little bit.
-Every kid does.
-Exactly.
Just separating the father/son
and player/coach, you know.
We know that when we're at
the golf course,
we're there for business
and when we're away from
the golf course, he's my dad
and one of my best friends.
So I'm very, very lucky
to have him.
-What does your dad do
when you do something bad?
Does he look at you
and go like...?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I remember playing baseball and
eventually I felt bad for my dad
because I was so bad
and all the dads kept giving
my dad advice on
how to make me better.
I was like, "Dad, you don't have
to come anymore."
-Look at you now.
-Look at me.
-One of the best baseball
players in the world.
I mean, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
We're like twins.
-Yeah.
-But it must be interesting.
Even as a dad to go like,
you got to make your moves.
Sometimes I'm more coach.
Sometimes I'm more dad.
And, like, how much pressure
do you put on your son?
-I mean, he is great because I
think my grandpa was pretty hard
on him, so he understands that
he didn't like that.
So he knew not to do it to me.
-Too much.
-Exactly.
So I'm very, very lucky,
like I said.
We have a great relationship.
And he's, I would say,
the opposite of -- sometimes I
would like him to be harder
on me because he feels like he
doesn't want to interfere.
He doesn't want to say something
that would mess me up.
But we've -- Not arguments,
but we've had these
conversations many times.
I'm like, "Dad, we're out here.
You're my coach.
You're not my dad.
You're out here to make me
better at golf, and that's what
you need to do."
-I love that.
I was recently golfing with
Justin Timberlake.
-The other J.T.
-Yeah.
The other J.T.?
-I guess he can go by that,
yeah, the other J.T.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, serious,
serious game.
I take it very seriously.
I was out there with
Travis Kelce and Patrick
Mahomes, and I had a shot
out of the bunker in the sand.
A lot of pressure.
-I think I saw that.
-Well, if you missed it,
we have it right here.
-Yeah.
-Oh! Go in! Go in!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, no big deal.
No big deal right there.
You saw it.
I know you wanted
some tips from me.
All that stuff.
We'll get to that later.
You know, I'll talk to your dad.
We'll figure it out.
-I think one of my favorite
parts about that video is,
you always hear the --
when people maybe overreact --
not saying that
that was overreacting.
But the whole --
-That was overreacting?
-Like act like you've been
there, and it was very clear
that you had never been there
in that moment.
[ Laughter ]
But I love it. It was great.
-That's so funny.
-It was great.
-That is so funny.
You're right.
I've never been there.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, sorry.
-While you've been competing
recently,
I know that you've been followed
by a film crew.
They're doing a documentary
coming out next year on Netflix.
-Yeah.
-Do you get nervous when
the camera is always on you or
are you just used to it now?
-I think, and to be perfectly
honest, in a situation
like this, I'm a little more
nervous with a film crew
because this is not
my comfort zone.
When I'm on a golf course,
that's what I do.
So I'm very comfortable
in that atmosphere.
But I think it's going to
be great.
It's going to be on Netflix
early 2023.
It's just going to give,
first off, a lot of people
outside of golf to take a look
at inside of golfers' lives.
But just see more of
the day-to-day.
I mean, they had moments where
they're in the car with me
driving to the golf course, or
they're watching me workout,
or they're having dinner with
some guys, whatever it is.
And I think it's going to
be a really cool thing
for people to see.
-You do this thing,
it's like your signature move.
After you take a shot,
you twirl your club.
And it's almost like, to me,
like a mike drop.
And I have a couple clubs here.
-Okay.
-I was just wondering if you
could just teach me how to do it
and just do it on
"The Tonight Show"?
-Yeah, I'd love to.
Where would you like to face?
Are we hitting this way?
-No, hit to the audience, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
So, I mean, we don't need to
take the full swing obviously.
But it's like, you know, you
follow through -- I want to make
sure I don't hit anything
up here.
-Yep.
-And then, you can kind of --
it depends on if you're left-
or right-hand dominant.
I think Tiger likes to go right
because then you can kind of
get the little -- you can get
the hand in there.
That was good. That was great.
That was awesome.
Or you know you can go left
and just -- it's just kind of
the swagger sometimes that
golfers can attempt to have.
I know we don't have a lot.
-No, I can try.
So, just up, follow through --
-It's just kind of natural.
You're following through,
and then just --
-And then spin it.
[ Cheers ]
Like that?
-That's good enough.
-Let's do it together. Ready?
-Alright.
-One -- Wait.
Two should be here, right?
-What's that?
Oh, so we're like --
-Oh, maybe this.
-Are we back to --
-No, now we're in a movie.
We're in a buddy cop movie.
Alright.
On two we'll be up here.
-Okay.
-So we need to be --
-So it's up on one?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-One, two, three.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Justin Thomas.
Check him out on the PGA Tour
this season.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Sam Hunt.
Stick around, everybody!